she's the best trader in the south
unbelievable trainer in the world in the
world all of our government officials
she's got the best inside information
warren buffett blackrock george soros it
is time to step aside because there's a
new star in town
and it's our beloved definitely not
corrupt speaker of the house it gives me
no pleasure to say this it breaks my
heart congresswoman nancy pelosi
also known as history's greatest stock
trader
in 2020 while the plebs were suffering
her and her husband made an insane 16.7
million dollars on the money they
invested which means they made a return
of more than 50
forget bitcoin nancy needs to open up a
hedge fund right now so i can dump all
my money into it
let's see how our 50 return compares to
some of the most legendary investors
blackrock the company that owns the
world was only able to make a measly 13
ew
and warren buffett uh warren buffett's
company berkshire hathaway only went up
by 2
in 2020 pathetic you see one of the
biggest person being a member of
congress is that you get to participate
in legal repeat after me legal insider
trading
that's why nancy pelosi was able to buy
tesla stock right before joe biden
signed off on pro ev laws that's why she
was able to buy options on 4 000 shares
of google right before the house
judiciary committee voted on anti-trust
regulation making her and her husband a
cool 5 million on this trade alone
if we traded on insider information the
sec would find us up to 5 million as an
individual or 25 million as a business
entity
and then they would throw us in a prison
filled with violent criminals for up to
two decades
and that's not even close to all the
trades nancy has made no no no right
before microsoft secured a 22 billion
dollar army contract her and her husband
exercised 1.95 million dollars with the
call options in 2008 visa offered nancy
pelosi access to ipo stock right before
the house had to decide on some
legislation visa opposed so her husband
bought 5 000 shares at 44 each and two
days later the price skyrockets to 64
her and her husband made a hundred
thousand dollars overnights
and the legislation it was never even
taken to the floor to vote
nancy pelosi has been a career
politician since she was a kid with her
dad she never had a career outside of
politics she never started a business
she was never in a position to build
real legitimate wealth and yet somehow
her and her husband now have an
estimated net worth of over 190 million
dollars
when her salary as a politician is only
around 220 000 a year
when asked about banning insider trading
for politicians this is what she had to
say because this is a free market and
people
where free market economy they should be
able to participate in that
if you thought insider trading was bad
on wall street it's time to take a walk
down capitol hill
[Music]
she's planning to retire to a community
of people she's demonized like if the
boss of san francisco is out of here i'm
definitely out of here
and if you want a free stock you can get
a stock worth between three dollars and
a thousand dollars when you go to
public.com jake tran with the link below
and create an account
see a lot of people are copying nancy
pelosi's trades in hopes of getting
returns as good as hers
but the problem is
she's only required to disclose her
traits within 45 days of it happening
and a lot can happen in 45 days you can
miss out on the entire trade on top of
that she's not the only one with a
killer portfolio
that's where public.com comes in public
is a social investing app that helps
people become better investors
it allows you to see what other people
are trading instantly like a twitter
feed before investing you can follow
people like graham steffen shelby church
to see what they're investing in and on
public you can buy full shares or slices
of stocks or etfs and you can buy more
than 20 crypto assets from classes like
bitcoin to things like doge
the app is completely free and there are
no commissions on standard stock trades
and they don't sell your trades to
market makers unlike other investment
apps so pause the video and go to
public.com jake tran with the link below
to get your free stock worth between
three dollars and a thousand dollars
when you create an account
that's public.com jake tran with the
link below thanks the public for
sponsoring this video
insider trading is when someone has
non-public inside information about a
company and then uses that information
to trade the company's stock
if you have a friend that works at the
ford motor company and he told you that
the government was about to make ford
the only company allowed to sell in the
us and no one in the public knew about
it you buying shares and ford would
count as insider trading
in most of the world insider trading is
illegal for obvious reasons even sweet
old martha stewart went to jail for five
months for insider trading that saved
her from losing just forty five thousand
dollars
not a million dollars just forty five
thousand dollars
and yet politicians are making millions
of dollars by trading on government
secrets and none of them are being
investigated
and none of this was more blamed than
right before the covet crash in 2020
in the month leading up to february 20th
2020 four u.s senators sold millions
upon millions of shares in hotels and
other major companies
four days later the stock market crashed
was it a coincidence were these four
senators just extremely lucky or did the
senate covet briefing that happened just
a month before on january 24th give them
an early warning that things were much
worse than the public expected
the four senators a mix of republicans
and democrats so between 4.1 to 12.8
million dollars worth of shares right
before the market crashes most likely
based on information they got during
their briefings
they knew hotels and the hospitality
industry was gonna take a hits they also
knew the market in general was gonna
nosedive so they got out ahead in front
of the cattle
and when they were questioned about this
coincidence well they had equally
frustrating answers
senator richard burr said he only relied
on cnbc news reports to make his trading
decisions apparently being briefed on
covet before the panic had nothing to do
with him selling his stock in wyndham
hotels
senator dianne feinstein who sold up to
5 million worth of stock in allergen
therapeutics said her husband was in
charge of the investments and she had no
idea what he was doing sure
senators jim inhofe and kelly lofleur
were the two others that dumped their
stock they also apparently knew nothing
about why they sold they were just lucky
while martha stewart went to prison for
five months because she saved a measly
45 000
these senators save millions upon
millions of dollars thanks to their
alleged insider trading an investigation
was open to look into them but that
investigation was dropped just three
months after the crash
and if you think this was the first time
politicians insider traded off of an
impending crisis you are sadly mistaken
back in 2008 it was even more lawless
why do you feel so compelled to do this
harry
we had no choice
if a politician buys stock in a company
because it's about to get a big
government contract that's not
technically seen as insider trading
because according to the law no material
corporate information is being shared
that's why leading up to the 2008 crash
congress members met with the treasury
got the inside scoop on the impending
disaster to come and 10 senators pulled
their money out of the stock market less
than two weeks before the crash happened
the stock market crashes and the plebs
are left to fend for themselves
and during this time there were not even
any disclosure laws these politicians
did not even have to report that they
made these trades so if you now aspire
to become a public servant to take
advantage of this insider trading you
gotta learn how to do it while
maintaining your pristine public image
and the way you do that is by offshoring
your insider trading a strategy that our
queen of stocks nancy pelosi knows all
too well
because this is a free market and people
we have a free market economy they
should be able to participate
you see even though this insider trading
is technically legal it doesn't look
very good in the eyes of the public
that's why we need some plausible
deniability so instead of you doing the
trace yourself as a public servant get
your spouse to do the training on your
behalf or even better yet get your kids
to do the training on your behalf
nancy doesn't do the trading herself her
husband does and her husband's traits
just happen to magically happen in
lockstep with important congressional
actions what can i say my husband just
has the midas touch spouses to
politicians still have to legally
disclose their trades but it gives you a
little cushion a convenient excuse that
you can tell the public that's why when
confronted with these hard questions
regarding insider trading this is what
nancy typically counters with the
speaker doesn't own any stocks as you
can see from the required disclosures
these transactions are marked sp for
spouse the speaker has no prior
knowledge or subsequent involvement in
any transactions
but the public wasn't satisfied with
these legal excuses so to appease the
plebs congress passed the stock act in
2012 because having the same people who
write the laws punish and police
themselves definitely works right
mr cantor's remarks about
the stock act and it's important that we
are here to do the people's business and
not to benefit personally from it
the stock act known as the stop trading
on congressional knowledge act was
created to stop this insider training on
capitol hill and make it illegal the act
was passed in april 2012 when the plebs
were all up in arms about this but once
they settled down and moved on to the
next outrage just a year later congress
made a very specific change they
loosened the stock axe disclosure
requirements to make it incredibly
difficult for the public to access their
filings
and even if the public could get their
hands on the information they needed
congress members have 45 days after the
trade to report it meaning they have a
massive window to profit before anyone
finds out
and the stock act is enforced by the
department of justice and the securities
and exchange commission the sec and who
funds both of these government agencies
congress
no one buys the hand that feeds them
so it's not exactly surprising that the
stock act is so selectively enforced
that's why i am proud to announce that i
am now running for senator
please donate to my campaign and i
promise you that i will dedicate my
existence to rooting out corruption and
letting you know what stocks you should
maybe buy or sell a vote for jake tran
is a vote for transparency but in all
seriousness loopholes like these have
led to the very lucrative profession of
the career politician were you going
broke and if you know how to play the
system you can leave a multi-millionaire
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you learn how to get rich as a
politician with insider trading now it's
time for a video to teach you about the
controversial life of our friend efree
jupstein the problem is if i made a
public video about him it would probably
get demonetized because of the nature of
the subject matter that's why this
upcoming documentary will only be
available to members of this channel you
won't be able to watch it anywhere else
and you can join by clicking the join
button below or with the link below if
you don't see the join button that way i
can still teach you guys about these
juicy topics about how the world really
works that they will never teach you in
business school while not getting
cancelled or demonetized this upcoming
documentary will be released near the
end of the month or early next month
along with a new private documentary
coming out every single month and unlike
business school it's only five dollars a
month to join
and if you join and don't think it's
worth it i will personally refund you
the money if you email me so click the
join button below to join now or you can
click this link to preview the other
documentaries that are already out by
the time you're watching this video
[Music]
[Applause]
you